oficialmente Janet yelen y sus homólogos
chinos comparten un objetivo común
aliviar la actual disputa comercial
entre los dos países el secretario de
estado Anthony blinquen que visitó China
antes que Janet jelen el mes pasado citó
sus palabras
como la secretaría yelen testificó ante
el congreso la semana pasada sería como
ella dijo desastroso para nosotros
desacoplar y detener todo el comercio y
la inversión con China
desacoplar esa palabra correcta Las
mayores economías del mundo son
interdependientes cada una es el mayor
socio comercial de la otra china exportó
536 mil millones de dólares en bienes a
los Estados Unidos el año pasado
mientras que Estados Unidos exportó 154
mil millones de dólares el déficit
comercial estadounidense fue lo que
desencadenó la guerra comercial del ex
presidente Donald Trump con China y la
batalla por el liderazgo en tecnología
altamente sensible a intensificado su
rivalidad Estados Unidos y sus aliados
temiendo que la alta tecnología sea
utilizada por el ejército chino han
frenado el acceso de Beijing a algunos
chips informáticos avanzados a
principios de esta semana china que es
el primer productor mundial de metales
raros necesarios para fabricar esos
Microchips y semiconductores dijo que
pondrá más restricciones a las
exportaciones el objetivo de Janette es
aliviar las tensiones pero se cree que
Estados Unidos prepa al mismo tiempo
nuevas medidas que podrían agravar la
crisis de Wall Street journal informó
que Estados Unidos podría restringir el
acceso de las empresas chinas a los
servicios en la nube y podría restringir
las exportaciones de chips de
Inteligencia artificial